very often when on this program we look
at clips from Congressional hearings
particularly clips of Republican members
of Congress who have an inflated sense
of self-importance and ego trying to
make themselves look like they are smart
and well prepared it's merely disaster
porn and what I mean by that is it's not
particularly instructive it's sort of
like wow they looked really dumb but
there's not that much to learn from it
today I have a very different example
for you that is extraordinarily
instructive and we're going to link it
actually to this recent report on the
origins or oranges of covid from the
Department of energy but before I even
do that let's talk about what we're
talking about a radical and repugnant
Republican Congressman Matt Gates
was called out yesterday in real time
for citing Chinese propaganda
now what happens here is extraordinarily
instructive with regard to confirmation
bias and not only the willingness but
the eagerness of these right Wingers to
accept any Source uncritically if it
confirms what they already believe so
let's take a look at this clip this was
a moment during the house armed services
committee where Matt Gates tried to sort
of gotcha call and call who's the U.S
defense under secretary for policy and
talk about the azov Battalion getting
access to American weapons uh Colin call
says I don't have any evidence of that
and Matt Gates says well what about this
and it turns out that it is over Chinese
propaganda you will also notice if
you're watching this clip that some of
the folks sitting in the audience really
seem to be enjoying this okay so let's
take a look and then we'll talk about it
is the azov battalion
less weapons
uh not that I'm aware of but
if you have information
consent to enter into the record the
global times investigative report that
uh indicate that talks about training
it's uh from the Atlantic council's
digital forensics research lab uh citing
the azov Battalion was even getting
stuff as far back as 2018. without
objection so ordered any reason to
disagree with that assessment is this
the I'm sorry is this the global times
from China no this is
well that's what you read
yeah would that be a reason uh I I as a
general matter I don't take beijing's
probably no no yeah just tell me if the
allegation is true or false I mean I
don't have any evidence one way or the
other as a general matter I don't take
beijing's propaganda at face value fair
enough I would agree with that
assessment April
the global times okay is a daily tabloid
newspaper published under the auspices
of the Chinese Communist party's
Flagship paper the people's daily it is
overtly Chinese propaganda now
it a a tabloid Chinese propaganda
newspaper might occasionally publish
things that are true but understand that
Matt Gates doesn't actually care about
that Matt Gates didn't have any idea
that he was repeating over Chinese
propaganda there and the the sort of
story of the day here
um is confirmation bias now okay Matt
Gates probably later went and yelled at
whatever staffer put that in his package
of stuff for the day and said I'm being
ridiculed the the country over for what
I just did and somebody's gonna somebody
is is gonna be fired or going to be
admonished for it but if you look at the
clip you can tell not only does Matt
Gates not know anything about the source
he doesn't care about the source and
this is a perfect example of how the
modern Republican party the Maga people
Etc they Embrace any source that tells
them what they want to hear or what they
already believe and they don't care
about the validity uh of the source the
analogy here is the Department of energy
report on covid Origins we talked about
this extensively yesterday on the bonus
show well the bonus show where you want
to make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
and we made an incredible amount of
money on yesterday's bonus show talking
about this the department of energy put
out a report about the origins of kovid
and says our assessment is it was an
accidental leak from a lab in China and
in the report the department of energy
says this is a low confidence assessment
and it's based on not super reliable and
very limited uh evidence and all of a
sudden the same right-wingers who for
three years have been saying I don't
trust anything the government tells us
about the origins of covid now they
trust a department of energy assessment
about the origins of covet why is the
Department of energy even assessing this
well that's a fair question but the the
real point is
they are now uncritically accepting a
government report about the origins of
kovid after saying for years you
couldn't trust government reports about
the origins of covet why because it
happens to be a report
admittedly low confidence admittedly
with with sketchy and limited data that
confirms what they already believe and
that's what this is fundamentally all
about one other this is like a bonus
clip from yesterday's hearing here is
friend of the show Eric swalwell
slamming Matt gates for bringing to the
hearing someone he met at a gun club
who had been charged with killing a
family member in April of 2019. this
isn't a joke okay this is this is where
we are today take a look one of the very
first committees the very first
Committee hearing of this Congress
Mr gates after we had all agreed on what
the committee's plan was going to be it
was going to be voice voted everyone
agreed Mr Gates wanted to offer an
amendment to say the Pledge of
Allegiance that's great every single
person on our side supported that
now I don't think he really genuinely
cares about saying the Pledge of
Allegiance no but he wanted to do it
again to own the libs and to see if we
would vote against it we didn't
but who did he bring in here to say the
Pledge of Allegiance right who did he
parade in here in a uniform
somebody that he met at a gun club he
said locally okay Mr sicolini had the
crazy idea that maybe we should vet the
people who come in here make sure
they're not insurrectionists Mr
McClintock
I am not kidding you Mr McClintock said
well it's not like we're gonna invite
somebody who committed murder
no he literally said that it's not like
we're gonna invite somebody who
committed murder
okay well
who did Mr Gates bring he brought
Corey Beekman
Corey Beekman in 2019
was in a standoff with the Michigan
Police
after he was arrested and charged with
murder assault with it to intent to
commit murder and two counts of felony
firearm possession
the family of the victims said Mr Gates
doing that it was like getting a dagger
stuck in our heart again we were
infuriated when we first saw it I was
disgusted with the whole thing
that's why there's a trust deficit here
you'd pull off a public stunt to try and
own the libs and what you did was you
brought in a guy who allegedly shot
two people and killed one of them yep so
a very very bad day yesterday for Matt
Gates and this is exactly what we
expected with Republicans controlling
the House of Representatives humiliation
after embarrassment after humiliation
after embarrassment and they are
certainly not disappointing Michael
Knowles on Whose program I have appeared
now wants to ban transgender ISM this is
the latest in the confused and uh quite
frankly
delusional delusionally obsessed
anti-trans right wing they have seized
on the idea
that they are going to get attention by
just being obsessed about trans and Matt
Walsh is essentially just known for
being anti-trans and he's gotten great
um uh publicity from it and great
attention and so now a lot of these
other right-wing Hangers On are uh
trying to mirror that and saying you
know if I just talk about trans people
all the time I'm going to get attention
and right Wingers who don't know any
better will will contribute and it'll be
great and they'll make money from it so
here is Michael Knowles and his new
thing is we just need to ban
transgenderism ban it speaking of the
law as a teacher yeah great new law in
Kansas
Kansas has become the first state to
pass by the way what is it about like
the tapping of the paper that is so
pompous and pretentious I don't know
what it is about that I'll play it for
you again great you not a great new law
there Taps the paper something about
that is just really annoying speaking of
the law as a teacher great new law in
Kansas
has become the first state to pass a
bill that defines woman as someone who
is biologically born female
that's it that's what a woman is
which means that this will ban men
and we will ban men who identify as
transgender women from using single sex
areas designated for women it's called
the women's Bill of Rights right it was
approved by legislators 26 very powerful
civil rights proposal to 10 on Thursday
only Republican support there
and the bill defines a female as someone
quote whose biological reproductive
system is developed to produce OVA uh-oh
who's but now we're getting that's going
to be a problem
developed to produce over while male
refers to anyone whose reproductive
system quote is developed to fertilize
the OVA of a female this is a beautiful
bill because
it doesn't just say don't trans the kids
it doesn't just say wait till eight
to introduce kids to transgenderism in
schools once they turn nine that's fine
it doesn't just say only miners can't
it's it bans transgenderism for all
practical purposes in the state for
everybody and it has to
in order for women to have the right to
have their own bathrooms you have to ban
transgenderism entirely ban it you can't
just ban it for the kids it's got to be
entirely while you're at it you should
ban racism too in order for women to be
able to have their own locker rooms at
the gym you have to ban transgenderism
entirely ban it in order to protect
businesses from having to participate in
weird businesses must be protected from
trans people occult sexual rituals like
the transgender transition you have to
ban transgenderism
entirely ban it okay as you can see
conservative it's not even uh I I
reflexively use the term conservative
but it's really extremist radical
rhetoric extremist radical right-wing
rhetoric against trans people is at
bloodthirsty levels
every how boring is it to just be a gay
man anymore and what I mean by that
tongue-in-cheek of course is
the they have moved on completely they
rarely cared about lesbians it used to
be all about trans men I'm sorry about
gay men now it is all piled on to being
in a bloodthirsty way anti-trans now of
course reasonable people would say how
do you ban transgenderism You Can't Ban
transgenderism any more than you can ban
homosexuality that being said what
they're talking about is criminalizing
specific Acts or
um behaviors or uh um Norms I guess you
would say and we know about the
horrifying history of that if we look at
that in history Beyond just sexual
orientation and gender identity now of
course there's this whole related thing
when you talk about
how you live versus what you feel and
acts versus all this stuff there's this
idea of one of the dangers of
transgenderism is people might fake
being trans either so they can get into
the women's bathroom and then photograph
or whatever you know things that are
already against the law
um but when you zoom out and you look at
the level of bloodthirsty viciousness
against the trans Community right now
why on Earth would anyone fake being
trans given how horribly trans people
are being treated and the level of
stigma against them now you know I'm
right there with you in saying might
someone
experiencing Strife in their life
wrongly come to believe for a period
that being in the wrong uh gendered body
um is what's causing them the problem
and then those people might explore that
and then go oh you know what this wasn't
the issue actually the issue is
something else and they moved Beyond it
sure right-wingers love to talk about it
and say you know there's all these
people who they they come out as trans
but then they go back to living uh uh as
the same gender that they were
um that matches their uh genitalia I
think is the way they like to say it
okay fine right I mean so so like
somebody might wrongly for whatever
reason think maybe this is the issue and
then it's not but the idea of the people
faking being Trans in order to do all of
these devious things like get into
bathrooms everybody wants to get into
bathrooms and locker rooms it's absurd
now of course with the whole Banning
thing the way this is defined what
happens if a woman's reproductive organs
were not properly developed by this
definition it sounds like that she's not
a woman oh well that's an exception what
if you're born intersex oh well that's
also an exception oh so we have
exceptions what makes those exceptions
any more legitimate than those who have
been diagnosed with gender dysphoria
it's just at that point it's just
arbitrary and um we saw a similar thing
when the gun control debate was about
well you should just be able to have all
arms
oh well like what about a shoulder
mounted RPG or well no not that oh so
you are okay Drawing the Line and making
exceptions so now it's just a question
of which exceptions do you consider
valid versus which ones do I consider
valid and many of these right-wing
arguments go down that path so
disgusting stuff from Michael Knowles
not surprising will have all of these
clips on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show make
sure you were subscribed to the channel
folks please we just closed out February
February or February I don't care okay
however you want to say it more than
three million people who are not
subscribed to the YouTube channel
watched our videos
to you folks hit the Subscribe button it
won't hurt you in any way it won't bite
you it won't do anything to you other
than affirm to YouTube that you like
what we're doing and then they'll
recommend our content to more people
that's youtube.com slash the
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I'm genuinely glad to see that more
people are sounding the alarm about the
danger that Ron DeSantis or as some know
him wrong Des Sanctus
uh poses to American democracy you know
I've been talking about this for a long
time and former guest on this program
expert on fascism Ruth Ben geot in
response to Jeb Bush endorsing Ron
DeSantis despite DeSantis not even being
a candidate at the time Ruth bengia
tweeted quote Ron DeSantis will destroy
our democracy with deadly Precision I
cannot emphasize enough how dangerous he
is so Ruth clearly comes down on the
side of what I've been saying for a year
now DeSantis is bad but the real danger
is that he's less incompetent than Trump
and thus is far more likely if he
becomes president to successfully
Implement a lot of these horrible and
disastrous ideas and increasingly the
proof is in looking at what he has done
in Florida for the last couple couple of
years now in a later segment we're going
to deal with this in a sort of different
way but sort of like as a reminder
what exactly is it that DeSantis has
quote succeeded at doing in Florida the
don't say gay Bill the entire anti-woke
Feud with Disney disturbingly
authoritarian business Freedom except
when we don't like what the business is
doing when we don't like the opinion of
your business the plan to overhaul the
Board of Trustees at the historically
liberal new College of Florida with six
new hand-picked conservative members
chilling when it comes to what supposed
small government conservatives want to
do in putting their hands right into the
specifics of what higher uh learning
institutions higher education
institutions are doing trying to
manipulate and control what is in that
advanced placement black history course
that became the subject of much
controversy a few weeks ago but the core
of all of this is that Trump and
DeSantis are both sort of wannabe
authoritarians Trump gets easily
distracted and is very incompetent so
through a sort of like adult ADHD where
he ends up just watching the TV in the
back of the room and his incompetence he
doesn't end up getting that much done
and so many of Donald Trump's failings
in a sense were from just kind of not
paying attention
Ron DeSantis on the other hand is far
less likely to be ineffective for those
reasons the January 6th Insurrection had
it been run by DeSantis would have had a
greater chance of succeeding not a
guarantee it would have succeeded
probably still would not have but it
certainly would have had more of a shot
Trump also does a lot of things because
he wants his base to like him and his
interest trumps interest in a lot of the
things he thinks of doing is geared
around I think my base will like this
and I think people will praise me for it
DeSantis genuinely seems to have like a
culture War delusion that he has to win
and as we've talked about being a True
Believer in a sense makes you more
dangerous now I I want to then add
another caveat because this DeSantis is
a complicated guy DeSantis is not a dumb
guy in the way that Trump is kind of dim
and part of me wonders whether DeSantis
really believes any of it personally but
as long as he's committed to it because
it's what he believes he has to do for
political expediency and to succeed he
is still a True Believer that it's what
he should do even if personally he
thinks a lot of these things are kind of
dumb ideas so the big hope against
DeSantis and the dangers that he poses
uh basically comes down to his complete
and total lack of Charisma and we're
going to look at some examples of that
in a moment his complete and utter lack
of Charisma might make him ill-suited to
actually defeat Donald Trump in the
national campaign that we seem to be
barreling towards even though DeSantis
hasn't officially announced anything yet
it is genuinely tough to find a less
charismatic person than Ron DeSantis at
least among the people in the major
Spotlight right now so that's Ruth
bengia accurately concerned about the
threat that DeSantis poses to democracy
let's now see what Rhonda Santos has
been up to in this growing civil war
against Donald Trump this might truly be
the most interesting Republican primary
that I have ever been involved in
covering by far even more than 2016.
we now have video of Ron DeSantis on the
Fox news program hosted by Jesse Waters
and Jesse Waters brings up to DeSantis
Trump's increasingly frequent uh and
unhinged attacks against him and for now
DeSantis approach has been to take the
high road I don't know that that will
work but that has been DeSantis approach
so far let's take a look at how DeSantis
responded yesterday when confronted with
the recent comments of Donald Trump all
right well former president Donald Trump
definitely thinking about you uh you
haven't said a lot uh I know you've
heard what he said and you you can see
this Collision is coming can't you yeah
well look Jesse I mean you know he used
to say how great of a governor I was and
then I win a big victory and all of a
sudden you know he had different
opinions and so you could take that for
what it's worth but you know at the end
of the day I think one of the reasons
I've been successful as Governor uh is I
don't really pay attention a lot of the
background noise I mean you know he's
obviously a big a big fish but I get
attacked all the time from every
different angle and you either put
points on the board or you don't and so
I just focus on delivering the wins and
I think we've done a pretty good job of
following through on our promises so
this is super interesting there's two
interesting things here one is this is
the first willingness we're really
seeing from DeSantis to actually go at
Trump now you might say David that's
very light all he's saying is Trump used
to praise DeSantis and now he doesn't
yeah right but that's one of the big
things that Trump does and Trump doesn't
like being called out for it which is he
he doesn't praise or criticize People
based on whether whether he genuinely
thinks they're doing a good job or not
he Praises or criticizes People based on
how they treat Trump and whether what
they're doing is useful to Trump so
first thing there that the Santa's is
doing is calling out Trump's hypocrisy
and how Trump's opinion of people just
waivers based on what's good for Trump
secondly the other uh interesting thing
here that we are seeing is that DeSantis
is starting to lay the groundwork
for approaching this campaign
from the perspective of Trump's just
like another guy and he even says in
there I get attacked all the time
and while he concedes Trump's a big fish
he is basically suggesting Trump is no
different in any serious way than
everybody else who attacks him and Trump
doesn't see himself as being like
everybody else Trump wants to be exalted
and held above everybody else so desant
is saying I get attacked all the time by
all sorts of people he's just grouping
Trump in with everybody else which Trump
is not going to like now and you know
DeSantis talks about his wins and I
mentioned this in the last segment a
little bit Florida 12th highest in covet
death rate per capita it's completely
mediocre in terms of crime it's right in
the middle completely mediocre on Health
Care completely mediocre on
infrastructure not one of the worst
nowhere near the best you know it's sort
of like Florida were way better than
Mississippi and Arkansas on all of these
metrics but we're nowhere near New York
or Massachusetts or Connecticut on any
of this stuff and I like Florida as a
place to go but it's not like they have
a great record for DeSantis to actually
write home about his accomplishments are
things that are virtue signals as I
mentioned before or you know the Banning
CRT we're going to have wrestling
matches really early in covid because we
we want to and taking control of Disney
because it went woke the anti-woke act
the don't say gay bill that's the sort
of thing that DeSantis is known for one
other funny moment from this interview
it really seemed like Jesse waters for a
moment thought DeSantis was going to
announce his run on his program didn't
happen I mean you're obviously running
for president you got the book you're
going around the country doing these
events I mean what's going on here
Governor right I have
I've got uh well I'm proud of I'm proud
of what we've done in Florida a lot of
people ask me how you do it yeah but
I've got over the next few months I've
got a big legislative session we just
want a big re-election Victor I made a
lot of promises we're going to deliver
on those promises so uh finish reading
the book I'm happy to come back and
discuss that with you but I'd like to
come back over the next three months and
discuss a lot of these legislative wins
that we're having for example uh we're
going to make sure our universities are
so now he's just going to talk about
something else he doesn't actually want
to address uh the presidency thing are
you from this Dei ideology and that's
going to be a great Bill to be able to
sign here coming up very soon all right
well former president Donald Trump
definitely thinking about you okay so
then we get into the the thing we looked
at before okay so desant is not ready to
announce yet he's starting to criticize
Trump but there's something even more
interesting that the DeSantis uh
campaign the DeSantis Administration did
let's talk about that next
uh Ron DeSantis had a book event
and he had all the Trump supporters
kicked out
is this free speech
is this inclusiveness is this a big tent
party this is one of my absolute
favorite things this week extremist
Laura Loomer who I think very little of
she went with a bunch of trump people to
a a DeSantis event
in Leesburg Florida it was a book event
books a million and the Trump people
were kicked out by security because the
DeSantis people said they've got to go
now remember DeSantis isn't even running
Trump's not desantis's opponent in any
official sense right now and in addition
to that Trump did endorse DeSantis for
governor albeit pretty half-heartedly so
it's wild that this is going on take a
look at this video of security
telling Laura Loomer and all of the
Trump people the DeSantis people are
kicking you out
yes
because of what you're wearing they told
me to say anybody wanted Trump has to go
right now
I mean listen all these people are nuts
but anybody wearing Trump has to go
right now is whacked stuff
[Music]
this isn't like you know if you try you
try to go to a if Ron DeSantis declares
that he's running and a bunch of people
try to get into the rally with Trump
signs obviously they're going to take
the Trump signs and probably kick you
out that's a political rally this is not
a political rally this is a very
different thing and they're still
kicking these people out
I'm sorry guys I have to call LPD now
okay he's got to call the police now
then there's another clip here where the
security guy even seems to say to these
folks you're acting like the far left
it's it's crazy what is happening but
the big story is Trump supporters kicked
out DeSantis doesn't want Trump
supporters there
we go
uh-oh
oh boy looks like our clip froze here
let's see if we can reset here and get
it going because this is a critical clip
are you acting like the far left because
yeah well you're acting like the far
left you're trying to get Trump elected
brilliant security guard huh same way
same way trying to get Trump elected
trying to get
too far left
I am a trump supporter technically
technically you shouldn't be over there
then I'm doing my job and so are we
where are we how crazy is this American
right wing movement just people
everybody's brain is just has been
replaced with mayonnaise but so
hold on to anybody who's wearing a trump
hat shirt anything anything Trump they
have to leave so we're you know Governor
DeSantis likes to pretend like he's a
governor in favor of free speech
but really he allows for elections to be
stolen by big Tech and now all right
anyway so they're going into those
criticisms
um and then here's one more clip of the
same uh listen guy uh the security guard
supports Trump but he's just doing his
job
and me come out to tell you guys not to
be here why he's here
he's here like he always talks about how
he's in favor of free speech like we
have a First Amendment right to be here
to rally and support president Trump
right you do right so but not now that's
so great you do have that right but I'm
suspending that right as regards to this
parking lot while Ron DeSantis is in
there signing signing books oh my God
this is going to be an insane primary so
not exactly four I guess uh the speech
of these people uh out in the parking
lot even not even inside the event
DeSantis just doesn't want to see them
um and this is uh uh I get it DeSantis
wants the book signing to be about him
rather than about Trump but when Trump
is supposedly a political Ally Who
endorsed you and who support you
welcomed and all of this stuff uh
kicking all of these people out is
pretty wild so we'll have all of these
clips on our Instagram you can search
Instagram for David Pacman show and if
you're interested in getting these clips
in Spanish for your Spanish-speaking
friends and relatives go to
davidpackman.com
Spanish make sure you're subscribed to
the Spanish Channel
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so I know
that Donald Trump is pretending like
Rhonda santis has no chance to beat him
in a primary and I think it's quite
possible that Ron DeSantis can't beat
Trump in a primary but I don't believe
for a second that Trump's not worried
Trump is posting almost daily about Ron
DeSantis on Truth social which we will
get to a little bit later but Trump
actually seems so panicked about
DeSantis that he is lying uncontrollably
about him all the time simple easily to
disprove lies here is a clip from Trump
yesterday on Sebastian gorka's show if
you're not up to speed on this program I
forgive you it's not exactly uh the this
show is not exactly on the Vanguard of
political analysis but in any case in
just a few seconds Trump tells multiple
lies about DeSantis while ignoring the
fact that the things which he is
accusing Ron DeSantis of he actually did
himself I won't even tell you what they
are let's see if you can pick them up
here well thank you very much it's nice
and we do have we have such incredible
spirit and love out there you see that
in these polls you know you have people
they started everybody thinks they're
wonderful I mean look Ron who I know
well he tried to cut Social Security he
wanted to bring the minimum age to 70 or
above he wanted to cut Medicare you know
that's not when people hear that they're
not going to be voting for him okay
there are so many lies in there already
so so there's two parts to this first of
all
Trump proposed cutting Medicare and
Social Security every year he was in
office either through the budgets that
he submitted which you can say well
that's a political document it wasn't
the budget that was okay but it's the
budget Trump submitted Trump's budget
proposal would have cut Medicare and
Social Security
and Trump also said if we win the
payroll tax will be rescinded that's how
you fund Social Security and Medicare
there is no way to get rid of the
funding source for all of Social
Security and Medicare
and not to cut Social Security and
Medicare can't do it it's impossible so
Trump proposed multiple different ways
that would lead to cuts to Social
Security and Medicare but Trump says
well DeSantis proposed cutting it I'm
not a defender of Ron DeSantis but it's
not really true that Ron DeSantis did
that what DeSantis did do three times
okay 2013 2014 and 2015. DeSantis voted
in favor
of Republican study committee budget
resolutions which if they passed were
non-binding and wouldn't actually have
been cuts to Social Security and
Medicare now you can say well his
intention was to
fine
it's an exaggeration given Trump's
background with cutting Social Security
and Medicare let's watch a little more
of this delusional clip and he's
certainly not going to win in a general
election but he's you're not going to
win the Republican primary in my opinion
either he wants to cut Social Security
that's not that's not good and numerous
times you know he's a disciple of Paul
Ryan
and Paul Ryan is the worst he's the
worst he destroyed Romney Mitt Romney
could have won that race but Paul Ryan
was a disaster as a pick that was the
wheelchair over the cliff if you
remember the famous wheelchair over the
cliff which is what they oh they stung
them with and it was very hard for them
to get away from it they didn't get away
from it right so you know there's a lot
there's a tremendous amount of love out
there it's uh it's pretty incredible
it's all love as you can imagine
um one more clip from this interview
here is uh someone proposing that
instead of wrong Ron Des sanctimonious
Trump instead referred to DeSantis as
Ron distablishment which is
man what what a primary we're up against
here well we'll talk about the next
election and uh your comments on the
ballot harvesting but uh you made we
need to get to those incisive comments
about ballot harvesting now three years
out you know the news on Truth social
and uh on your research with your new
nickname for the governor of Florida run
the sanctimonious uh Mr G does somebody
else has come up with a a another
nickname what what is the nickname you
have for us Jeff it's got to be Ron's
establishment Mr President Ron The
Establishment what do you think of that
that's not bad I've heard worse you know
they came out with lots of different
names meatball I didn't like that one
too much but uh they came out with a lot
of different names and that's not bad
I've heard of worse yeah all right so
Trump is workshopping uh other nicknames
for wrong Des Sanctus
um there he is just telling lies and
he'll continue to tell those lies for as
long as he's allowed to do it at some
point maybe Ron DeSantis will take it
head-on and say it's not true your
budgets actually sought to cut Social
Security and Medicare for the time being
DeSantis isn't running so he's not
taking it on from a policy perspective
all right let's now move from the
Sebastian Gorka program to Troth Central
Trump on his social media platform
melting down because Fox News is
spreading Ron DeSantis propaganda now
I'll be honest Fox News is spreading Ron
DeSantis propaganda Trump's not wrong
about that what's funny is he doesn't
seem to get that fox news's priority
here is to maintain access to power
whoever ends up holding the power and so
yes Fox News does seem to have a
preference for DeSantis but they're not
going to abandon Trump if Trump wins the
first couple of primaries Fox News will
be back to Trump and eating out of his
hand that's all Fox cares about uh here
is what Trump posted
to truth social saying quote Fox News is
promoting Ron Des Sanctus so hard and so
much that there's not much time left for
real news there was never real news on
Fox but okay reminds me of 2016 when
they were pushing Jeb the new Fox poll
which have always been purposely
terrible for me has Trump crushing de
sanctimonious but they barely show it
instead they go with losers like Karl
Rove Paul Ryan and now even Jesper who
have been wrong about everything isn't
there a big beautiful capital and
network which wants to do well and make
a fortune besides fake news now as a
reminder here's the promo this is
unabashed Ron DeSantis propaganda here's
a promo for the show Fox did
Fox Nations hit docu series is back who
is Ron DeSantis we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob
he was in the Middle East advising Seal
Team One to advise them you have to be
the best of the best he's a good man
he's a good husband he's a good father
is this Ron desantis's opportunity to
run for higher office I think it is who
is Rhonda Santos streaming now yeah this
is the epitome of uh of news attainment
right I mean this is this is not meant
to be informative this is supposed to be
entertaining to the Fox News audience
and it is over propaganda so Trump isn't
wrong to be posting about that lastly
Trump then posting uh about polls uh
Trump crushes DeSantis in Fox News poll
and again it is not untrue when you look
at the polling data right now when you
have multi-way polls meaning Trump
DeSantis Haley Tim Scott Mike Pence Mike
Pompeo and whoever else Trump does quite
well when it is Trump versus DeSantis
head on it is much less good for Donald
Trump and so Trump is not wrong about
that we are going to continue following
the polling but most importantly we are
going to continue following the growing
Civil War within the Republican Party
related to this CPAC starts tonight the
conservative political action conference
it's going to be a pretty low end CPAC
because cpac's organizer Matt schlapp
has been accused of groping a male
staffer uh despite being anti-gay
personally
um and this seems to have led to a lot
of no's for people who have been invited
to CPAC we are going to start our live
coverage of CPAC Tonight on YouTube
twitch and Facebook so I hope you will
tune into that in my curiosity about
this year's CPAC this year's first CPAC
they seem to do it five times a year now
is going to be do they take any kind of
overt position on the 2024 Republican
primary does CPAC remain overtly
pro-trump does CPAC become agnostic do
they pretend there is no primary going
on is it just up to whoever speaks one
of the opponents of trump Vivek
ramaswamy whose campaign is not exactly
launched with much fanfare he is
actually going to be a speaker at CPAC
so it's going to be a very interesting
thing to see it will be live starting
tonight on YouTube twitch and Facebook I
hope you will join me and remember you
can get it all truly get it all on the
main YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show if you are not yet
subscribed Please Subscribe folks this
is my Jeb Bush please clap moment please
subscribe
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
we talked a couple of weeks ago about
this kind of sad downfall of Bill Maher
a guy who I generally used to like and
still think has valuable insights on
some issues I have a really great
illustration that was sent to me by a
viewer yesterday about where Bill Maher
really has gone off the rails and this
is a clip from an interview he just did
with Jake Tapper from CNN Bill Maher has
been sort of anti-woken that he's been
arguing against wokeness and saying that
this aspect of the left is is bad and
you know to the extent that the left
goes too far with identity politics or
whatever the case may be you can find no
bigger critic than me when I find an
element of the left that I don't like I
call it out and there are sometimes some
consequences to it some in my audience
don't like me doing it but I try to make
those call outs proportional to how
significant these things are within the
left fine Bill Maher is asked what is
woke and he spits out a word salad it's
like a chop chop it's like a confetti
salad the ones where you could it's
almost like little tiny bits it makes no
sense he says things that aren't true
and this clip
is really a microcosm of everything that
has gone wrong with Bill Maher take a
look at this and wokeness like how do
you define wokeness because I hear
people use the term all the time and I
mean something different to
to everybody well again I think it's
this collection of ideas that are not
building on liberalism but very often
undoing it
I mean five years ago Abraham Lincoln
was not a controversial figure among
liberals we like to
now they take his name off schools and
tear down his statues okay neither of
those things are happening so Bill Maher
is asked to Define woke and he says it's
anti-liberal stuff like the left taking
down statues of Abe Lincoln and renaming
schools named after Abe Lincoln I spent
a while researching whether those things
were happening there is one example of
an Abe Lincoln statue that was taken
down
and it was a really weird statue in
Boston where there was like that a black
man Weeping at the feet of Abraham
Lincoln and and it's a really weird vibe
okay
um it's been a controversial statue for
a while it doesn't actually have
anything to do with the recent statue
debate and it was removed and it was a
really weird statue but statues of Abe
Lincoln are not being removed there is
no effort to remove Abe Lincoln statues
you might be able to find one person who
went to some town hall meeting and said
we should get rid of enabling conception
but there's no actual effort going on to
remove them they're not being removed
there's this one weird one with a black
man Weeping at the feet of Abe Lincoln
that's it just doesn't really make sense
in 2023 so that's very deceptive and
then number two Abe Lincoln's name is
being removed from schools I have not
found a single example of Abe Lincoln's
name being removed from schools what I
found was a story from January of 2021
where San Francisco said we might name
like all the schools from the era during
which there was slavery and that
included one named after Lincoln it
didn't happen okay they kept the name so
one school might have been renamed and
it wasn't so so far
his two examples of what wokeness is are
things that are not happening Lincoln
isn't good enough for you
um you know five ten years ago I
Bedrock liberalism was we are striving
to be a colorblind Society where we
don't see race
um of course we see it but it doesn't
matter
that's not what Welk is woke is
something very different it's it's
identity it's we see it all the time
it's always the most important thing
okay so listen as far as identity
politics goes I'm critical of identity
Politics on the left but the identity
politics is overwhelmingly on the right
does it exist on the left Shore I've
called it out for example when the
women's March said
that Jewish women are not intersectional
enough to be on the leadership because
they're really just privileged white
women
I thought that that was the left doing
identity politics in a way that is
disgusting and destructive and I called
it out when these things happen I call
them out but look at the identity
politics happening on the left
Christians are oppressed white people
are oppressed Nikki Haley why are you
running well I I'm not going to tell you
anything I disagree with Trump on but
I'm younger I'm a woman and I'm Indian
that's that's identity politics and I
don't hear any of these anti-woke
leftists calling it out I would respect
Bill Maher way more if he said I'm
against identity politics anywhere I see
it and here's a couple of examples of it
on the left it's always vaguely said the
woke identity politics give us specific
examples and I will be right there with
you in criticizing them but you've got
to point out that the identity politics
cudgel is being used by the right when
the identity politics is overwhelmingly
coming from them I would like to I would
like to see Bill Martin take that
approach as opposed to this word salad
definition of woke I don't think that's
liberalism I mean I could mention so
many issues like that I remember doing
um that show on HBO comic relief for the
homeless and
the idea then again among liberals I
thought was you know for the sake of
compassion can we get these people off
the street so they remember the question
was what is woke a roof over their heads
and now it's like how dare you try to
move the homeless this is where they
live it's like again you change the
definitions and then you say I'm more
conservative I believe what I've always
believed now that's true okay so the uh
as I pointed out a couple weeks ago
a lot of the Bill Maher stuff like the
kind of anti-vaxx and you know things
like this it's not actually new the
difference is that the environment has
become a more welcoming one for these
ideas of Bill Mars and so they're
getting more attention but Bill Maher's
been doing a lot of this routine for a
very long time so check out my video on
YouTube called they don't even know what
woke means I explain more about this
inability to Define woke uh but now Bill
Maher asks for a definition mentions two
things about Abe Lincoln that aren't
true and then vaguely mentions identity
politics and a comedy special that he
once did not hugely compelling stuff
Candace Owens wants to bring back a form
of eugenics where you breed children to
be better at math the way you might
breed a dog to be more or less
aggressive or have different coloring on
its fur this is absolutely and utterly
insane stuff is it Nazi stuff is it not
I mean you you tell me here is Candace
Owens explaining the South Koreans are
breeding for math skills we should have
a breeding program so yes it is correct
to say that these dogs or bred to fight
they were bred to attack and they were
bred to kill over many many years and
the question of whether or not breeding
works of course it does the question of
whether or not Darwinism is real of
course it is you can breed for Heights
you can breed for intelligence you can
breed for stupid if you there's
something about the use of the word word
breeding that is like extremely icky I
really want to right obviously this can
take place you can breathe for
athleticism we see examples of this all
the time but it's important to note yeah
that just because you are bred in one
way or the other does not mean that you
are locked into that permanent state
right so right now uh the most
mathematically capable people in the
world are Koreans does it mean that
Koreans are forever going to be the most
mathematically capable people in the
world we could start breeding Americans
do better at math we can start doing
what they do over in Korea
um or we could not you mean having
education that works and we can remain
probably the dumbest mathematical
country in the world okay so the the the
I don't know that the funny is the right
word but the ironic thing here is
Candace has almost got it she's she's
almost got it you don't have to breed
children for math just educate them
educate the people that we have now why
wait to have a multi-generational
breeding program for math educate people
now we could better fund education which
she's against many of her cohort want to
eliminate the department of energy many
of her cohort want to teach creationism
in science class along the theory of
evolution
they are doing the dumbing down they
want to get rid of a whole bunch of
books they want to require things be in
the curriculum that aren't going to make
anybody better at math she's against all
of that stuff we should be better at
math we also shouldn't be teaching
creationism in science class and you
know she goes to the South Koreans are
bred to be good at math
it is widely
studied that there are a number of Asian
cultures that focus on and emphasize
Scholastic Excellence among their young
when schools are when well-funded and
well supported and teachers are
appropriately paid and they can that
allows the attraction of better teachers
to the job
they're against all of the stuff breed
you know it's like she's going eugenics
where what you need to do is you need to
fund education and it's the similar sort
of thing what you know some some of
these folks that uh they they like to
talk about
um you know what actually I don't even
need to give other examples these these
really stand on their own she's almost
got it why aren't we creating an
environment in which students are better
at math well a lot of it is not about
genetics it's about her movement saying
do all of these things which weakens
education and and it's
it's frustrating to see that she's so
close but the narrow worldview won't let
her realize oh wait maybe like all the
stuff I say about defunding public
schools isn't going to get us to what we
need
um I don't know that she's ready to to
deal with that but she's of the mindset
of we've got a problem let's use
Eugenics to fix it we don't have to wait
that long we can fix it right now with
education
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is yet another
caller thinking it's time for me to get
corrected about the vaccine
listen to this
hey David listening to your show now
boy you are doing some major back
pedaling on what you are guilty of with
regards to the vaccine I'm back pedaling
Mama that sounds interesting let's see
if the voicemail explains in what way
I'm backpedaling
and
for the entire time
of any
real debate any open dialogue any
scientific inquiry
for anything other than
this vaccine even now you're just
telling all vitamin D is good for
everything guys like that's
David go back in your own tapes I've
been saying all along the same thing
about vitamin D and you can hear you you
say anybody who says you need Vitamin D
is an anti-vaxxer literally never said
it
be canceled that was you and my my
suggestion to you uh to well my
suggestion to you is to criticize me for
things I've actually said sir kind of
repair your credibility yeah is play us
some clips of some stuff that you played
in 2020 2021 you know let's hear it
let's hear you get on today see what I
said here I'm being a reasonable so
listen there has been no back pedaling
let's take these things one at a time
let's first talk about the vaccine the
first vaccine tailored to the original
covid variant very effective at
preventing infection and transmission it
was a really good vaccine not only at
keeping you out of the hospital and
alive if you got covered but it was a
good vaccine at preventing you from
getting coveted at all as the virus
changed and the vaccine started to be
modified to keep up with it the vaccines
became less and less and less effective
at preventing infection I at no point
said anything other than that to the
point where now the vaccine really is
about keeping you alive and keeping you
out of the hospital it is not a vaccine
that is preventing infection at this
point in time I hope we can get to one
that does at no point have I backpedaled
and at no point have I made a claim
about that that didn't match what was
actually happening in the real world as
far as vitamin D vitamin D
uh zinc vitamin C
Ivermectin uh hydroxychloroquine we
looked at all of these things and my
Approach early was we don't have
evidence right now that these things
prevent covid or our treatments for
covid as we gained evidence we learned
okay Ivermectin doesn't work we've now
we have a good test we have a good trial
and it doesn't work hydroxychloroquine
doesn't work vitamin C and Zinc don't
seem to do anything to shorten the
duration vitamin D does seem like it is
generally good for fighting off
infections all along from the very
beginning I said to everybody in my
audience
I supplement my vitamin D in the winter
months
even if it doesn't do anything to
prevent or help you get over coveted
specifically it is a good thing to
maintain an adequate level of vitamin D
and that continues to be what I say
there has been no backpedaling
whatsoever so please criticize me for
things I've said sometimes people
criticize me for things other hosts have
said and they're like oh I actually
heard that on a different show but I
guess it was David I don't know if it's
an honest mistake apology accepted I
know you're not going to apologize sir
but uh there has been no back pedaling
thank you very much we're going to talk
on the bonus show today
about the latest on student loan debt
relief we are going to talk about Iowa
legislators proposing a ban on same-sex
marriage I know it's 2023 this is not a
show from from 2013. it's 2023. that's
what they're proposing let's ban
same-sex marriage and we will talk about
the post office buying almost 10 000
electric vehicles and 14 000 charging
stations very interesting stuff all of
it on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access
foreign